[Music]
let's go to taryn in fresno it's an all
california show today what's up taryn
hi dr daniloni thank you so much for
taking my call thank you for calling and
i don't know why i'm so loud today i
feel loud sorry i would if you just me
wake up it's okay but if you and me like
met at a coffee shop i wouldn't be like
hello tara i wouldn't do that i don't
know why i'm yelling so dumb
so let me i'm gonna back that thing up
okay
um
we'll slap it up flip it reverse it okay
so hey good morning taryn what's up how
are we doing
i'm good how are you i feel so much
better to talk to you like a human not
like i'm like yeah radio i am good so
what's going on how can i help
yeah so um
so my dad has been in prison my entire
life
well let's just get right into it
it's a great way to start a conversation
right
hey so what happened why has he been in
jail your whole life
um so he was um
he was sentenced when i was about three
months old um
and he is a sex offender okay um
so yeah that happened when i was just a
few months old he's been gone ever since
were you the victim
i was not no okay what was the what was
the offense
um so
without getting like into too much
detail or getting too graphic um
he was he had a lot of uh
abuse when he was growing up um from you
know other people like in the church and
his family
and that kind of progressed to him doing
the same kind of abuse when he was an
adult okay uh
he was like
yeah okay all right
um okay so he's been in jail your whole
life how and how many years is that 20
years 30 years
uh 25 25 okay
yeah
so he is getting released uh at the end
of next month
can i just guess does he want to yeah
does he want to kick it all back up and
make up for lost time and get his
daughter back
uh
kind of okay so i
he
probably the past like a year or two i
mean we will
we'll write letters back and forth here
and there um to stay in contact um we
have kind of tried to heal the
relationship a little bit um but
riding back and forth and you know
with visitation and everything you know
then covet hit no visitation was allowed
to happen that wall was always there so
it was kind of easy
and it was okay but now that he's
getting out and it's all in person
it's like
i don't even know where to start so i
guess my my main question for you is
how do i
how do i maintain this relationship in a
healthy way with
healthy boundaries i guess is my
question
um okay so i'm gonna lean into a
hard thing okay and the hard thing is
this
i'm gonna talk to somebody else about
their dad
and i'm gonna be really honest and
that can sometimes cross my own personal
boundaries which is to not say ugly
things about other people's parents
is that cool
it's it's okay it really is
okay
um
so let's start it this way
take all of
the daughter's supposed to fill in the
blank with their dad supposed to love
their dad and respect their dad take the
fact away that he's your dad
let's just talk about this guy let's
call him let's call him dan let's talk
about dan
what do you think of dan
[Music]
be honest
um i
probably not the best things but i mean
like
hey that's what like that's what i want
to hear you say out loud like what do
you think about dan
because here's my guess my guess is you
have wrapped up your feelings
and what you really think
and your guts
and your rage and your anger and your
heartbrokenness
under
this
daughter duty to dad
i may be way out of line there but
that's my guess
and you have tried to make it work
because i'm supposed to forgive i'm
supposed to burn my dad
what do you really think about dan
honestly i was really disgusted with him
i i just didn't understand how someone
could do that even
even with all the abuse he had as a
child i mean i understand
how it led up not saying that i agree
with it
but
everyone's still got a choice
everyone's still got a choice could care
less what happened yeah yes
and i was
i was very angry i was very disgusted
for a long time we we didn't talk for a
number of years actually just because of
the whole situation um once i was old
enough and i
found out everything that happened once
you know that my mom and him actually
were able to tell me what happened
and how old were you when that happened
um
it's probably about 15 or so so did they
was there a big cloud did they lie to
you for the first 15 years of your life
about where dad was
um
so my mom was my mom did lie for a
number of years staying where he was
she
would just kind of make up random things
i don't remember all of them but it of
course it was avoiding the fact that he
was in prison
um he was actually telling my mom and i
that he was innocent this entire time
and then when i was about 14 or 15 or so
he actually came to my mom and me like
wrote us a letter and told us that he
was actually guilty of all those things
so
he
told my mom and i the truth at the same
time and then my mom kind of gave me a
more detailed explanation so it kind of
hit everybody
suddenly yeah and it was it was
surprising and that was the time that i
didn't really talk to him for a while
um probably till i was about 18 or 19 or
so he kind of wrote me out of the blue
and he wanted to apologize for
everything that he did and that he's
been going through you know treatments
and therapy and
kind of taking
his mental illness into consideration
and trying to find treatment for that so
just basically that he's changed and
that he's trying to forgive himself and
move forward and all that and
ever since then it's just kind of been
on and off and rocky and it's to this
day it's still hard to talk to him yeah
and i just don't know what to say
sometimes i don't know how to have a
conversation with this guy sometimes and
it's hard so that's just kind of where
i've been at man well thank you for
walking us through that
so yeah
i don't want to miss the scope of this
trauma and you've lived this but i want
to put words to it
your dad left you
and if he had left you and your mom for
another woman when you were three months
old that would have been trauma
because you would have spent your
childhood years wondering what was so
great about that other woman
that dad left me
like i'm his baby girl and he left me
and then there was the trauma of finding
out that your mom lied to you for years
whether she thought she had to or not
whatever that's not the point the point
is that it happened
i'm not about blame and all that it
happened
yeah and so then there's a fracture in a
relationship between you and your mom
and my guess is y'all will ride or die
at that moment because you're all she's
all you had
and then to find out
i
i don't
i don't nothing i
know is true
because mom the one person i had didn't
tell me the truth about my whole life
and then to find out
oh there's dad he's back
oh by the way
he did the most evil egregious thing a
person can do which is take the
innocence away from a child
and by the way daughter
if you
will have me back
i'd sure love to come back
and so then this whole thing wraps up in
a pretty bow and a package and handed to
you which is
you get to heal yourself from all this
trauma
and you get to heal all these things and
it all rests on you which is another
trauma
it's kind of like my friends i've had
several friends who get cancer and they
will tell me
almost worse than the cancer diagnosis
is that they are now responsible for
making every person in their life feel
better and that's what just happened to
you
now it's your job
what are you going to say to dad are you
going to have dad over are you going to
let me back in your life and suddenly
you the child are responsible for
healing these adult relationships
and so i need
like i know you know this i'm not
telling you that you don't know you're
clearly brilliant and you're clearly
been through tough as nails you've been
there a lot
but the trauma is that you've
experienced that your body has had to
navigate is deeper than just your dad
committed an atrocity
it's that since you were three months
old you have been
uh a balloon on a string just floating
up in space
does that does that ring true with your
body does that ring true
i haven't really ever put words into it
or put it into words but yeah it does
my guess is you are
really good at your job
and you don't take crap from anybody or
you tape crap from everybody and you say
i'll take care of it you're either a war
finder or a peacekeeper which one are
you
i'm a peacekeeper there you go
i will make sure that everything goes
and when a peacekeeper is a peacekeeper
for a long time the one person that
doesn't have peace in their soul is them
and i just want to tell you i
i could probably
get choked up here pretty quick if i let
myself i'm sorry this happened to you
because you're kind of awesome not kind
of you're all the way awesome
and you deserved a better shot out of
the canon than you got
and you deserve to be anchored into
people who say i freaking love taryn
she's incredible
and if i'm the first person to ever tell
you that shame on everybody around you
but i'm glad i get to be the person to
tell you that
are you married
i am yeah
somebody good
yeah very good
a good anchor
oh yeah
do you ever get to put the peacekeeper
down and just go full tearing
just go full
either it's full rage or full dance or
full we're turning the strobes on and
we're turning on the house music and
we're gonna rock this thing on
or full
i can be wildly intimate with this
person like are you able to let
peacekeeper go
um
probably the only person i can do that
with is with my husband okay
he's he's seen me try so hard to make
people happy
and i just exhaust myself or i get sick
or whatever ends up happening and he
just kind of
he kind of tells me when to just be
myself and relax or he'll sometimes
he'll come in and he'll pick up the
pieces so i don't have to
so here's your work
your work is not
fixing your family
that was done to you that's not your job
your job is to heal tearing
and
man what a stud that you married that
loves you enough to walk alongside you
my dream and hope for you taryn is that
in short order
you don't need somebody else
to tell you when you've done enough
you'll be able to trust your body for
the first time
you'll be able to trust taryn for the
first time
you'll be able to stand tall and say you
know what i want today
craziness
you know what i want today i wanna we're
knocking off work and we're gonna dance
until we can't move you know what i
wanna do i'm going hiking until my legs
don't work anymore i want
and that's the work
because i think you've been nice long
enough
and i think you've squashed taran for a
long long long time
and none of this is why you called right
yes and no
so
here's the deal about your dad
any sort of relationship you do or don't
have is on your terms
your dad cashed in his ticket
when he chose to steal
the most precious thing from a person
which is their innocence
from one two twenty fifty however many
kids there were
he made a choice to say
i am no longer
going to have influence or
um
presence
in the life of my one
sacred daughter
i'm choosing that
and i know he's got demons and i know
he's been hurt and evil and hurt people
hurt people all that but he made a
choice i'm choosing
this
over
influence and presence in my daughter's
life
and that's a choice he made and he's got
to live with that and you've got to live
with that your mom's got to live with
that the whole ecosystem has to live
with that
and you have to let the fantasy go and
this is a hard thing for peacekeepers
because peacekeepers live in a fantasy
world that if they just do the right
things in the right order that everyone
else's world will be okay
and that's not real
so you have to let the fantasy go
that he's gonna come out you're gonna
have this big hugging moment and he's
gonna slowly start coming around and one
day he'll be able to hang out with your
kids and it will be lovely and we got
dad back
that's not real and that's not going to
happen
no
you've got to build something totally
new and you got to start over with all
that knowledge in mind
and if you say
you know what after doing some work on
taryn i don't want to be in a
relationship with this guy don't
no obligation
if you say
for the first two years you're out of
jail you can write one letter to my
house a month i will burn every other
letter that comes and i will not see you
in person
for two years you can write me a letter
and then maybe i'll meet with your
parole officer and see if you are living
up to the recidivism rate for
um
this type of sex offender is
the odds of him recommitting are very
high
right and so
i get to do whatever i want to do
because i'm freaking tearing
right
yeah and so hear me say
i want you to be completely and totally
at peace
with whatever you want to do
and however you want to build it
and the moment somebody sends you a mean
text and says well you know what you
should done blocked next
the moment your mom says well i was
hoping we could all get blocked tech
next
because for the first time taryn's not
going to be keeping everybody else's
peace taryn's going to keep peace inside
of taryn
which is going to give her husband peace
it's going to give her kids peace it's
gonna give her workplace and her
environment peace
and then maybe
i'll reach out to that guy
or hey tell me i'm all crazy taryn tell
me i'm bananas and say no i really
really want a relationship with him
you can do that too but it's on your
terms hear what i'm saying
yeah i do so here's what i want to have
happen i want you and husband to go out
i want you to let him talk
i want you to let him speak into he
loves you he's walked alongside you he's
seen you hurt he's seen you cry he's try
he's seen you try to make everybody
else's world okay
both professionally personally everybody
i want to get his thoughts on
letting dad back in your life
and then
i want you to let it go
for the first time
whether you have to write it down
whether you just get a laptop and start
typing you have permission to type
because i have a feeling that a lot will
come out and
your hand may not be able to catch up on
the yellow pad but right right right
right right right taryn
what do you really feel where do you
want to go where do you want to live
what do you want to do what world you
want to create
you've been creating everybody's world
for a long long time taryn
who do you want to be what do you want
to be
start there and then decide i want to
let this disgusting person back in my
life
i believe in redemption
but sometimes redemption has a slow long
arc
and to anyone out there who hurts kids
god help you
don't
stop go get help quit turn yourself in
whatever but stop
because you don't just hurt the kids you
hurt their entire family systems you're
the entire kids
ecosystem you hurt your kids your spouse
their kids their grandkids
that type of evil roils through and just
burns through generations